the symbol of equality looms over a
parliament engulfed in a row over reform
years of debate reached this Crescendo
campaigners concerned making it easier
to legally change gender a step too far
the difficulty with
the
man
[Applause]
with precious little safeguards these
changes speed up the existing process no
diagnosis of gender dysphoria or medical
reports are required applicants must
live in their acquired gender for three
months rather than two years and 16 and
17 year olds can also apply for a gender
recognition certificate for the first
time it's easier to play for banker and
easier for a passport
a relief for the trans Community
including Dylan I socially transitioned
when I was 13 it was pretty obvious for
me I knew I wanted to try obviously if
it'd been the wrong thing I would could
have just gone back
is kind of an administrative thing it
doesn't affect your right to spaces it's
not kind of a path to be trans and trans
women trans men have been using the
toilets of their choice for years I know
I have
this has been politically bruising for
Scotland's first Minister Nicholas
sturgeon who brought forward this
legislation one of her cabinet ministers
resigned the first time that's happened
over a policy matter during her
Premiership the first time it's happened
since the SMP came to power in 2007 and
there is a suggestion this may not be
the end of the road the UK government
may not recognize this new Scottish
system or these gender recognition
certificates I think that would be
disappointing if they chose to do that
and they already recognize grc's from a
number of other countries that have
similar systems to our own so that would
be rather inconsistent and of course
they themselves were Consulting about
this back in 2018 and then of course
they changed Direction a landmark ruling
bringing this sometimes toxic debate to
its Crescendo Conor Gillis Sky News
Edinburgh